JOHN D.E. GABRIELI: ADHD
stands for attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder.
It's a very big problem.
The current estimates are
that 11% of children--
more than one out of 10--
meet the diagnosis
for ADHD, and there's
been a remarkable growth
in the number of adults who
meet the diagnostic criteria.
The literature is that
about half of children
no longer meet the diagnosis
by the time they're adults.
Often there are
remaining difficulties
so they don't outgrow it
as if they never had it,
but often they have
considerable improvements
that shows up in their
educational and occupational
success.
SUSAN WHITFIELD-GABRIELI:
In this study
we're interested in
investigating the default mode
network and patients
who had ADHD.
The default mode
network are regions
that have been known to
be typically activated
more during rest-- and
those three regions
are the medial
prefrontal cortex,
the posterior cingulate,
lateral parietal cortices.
The default mode network
is the first time
we can have a neural
system that reflects
self-referential processing.
AARON MATTFELD: What's been
found in typically developing
people is we have this synchrony
in your default mode network,
so when these regions go
up, the other regions go up.
In ADHD, that's not the case.
And that's been
identified in adults
and that's been
identified in children.
What it hasn't
been identified is
people that have been
diagnosed as children
and then followed
longitudinally,
and that's what's
unique about our sample.
So these subjects came in.
We got structural scans,
diffusion weighted scans,
and one of the scans we got
was this resting state scan.
And so during that
scan, their job
was just to lie as still
as possible for six minutes
and think of nothing
in particular.
So in the remitter
group, the question was,
would their brain look
like that of people
that persisted with their
ADHD diagnosis into adulthood
or look like controls?
And what they looked
like was like controls--
like people that had never
been diagnosed with ADHD.
SUSAN WHITFIELD-GABRIELI:
In other words,
it looks like the
remitted ADHD somehow
were able to normalize their
resting state functional
connectivity to
the PCC and attract
the current clinical status.
AARON MATTFELD: It wasn't
that the people that remitted
were completely like controls
in every way possible.
We also know, at
rest, that there
are these task related networks,
these task positive networks.
And we wanted to
see the relationship
between the task
positive networks
and the default mode
network in our sample.
So in control, they show
an anti-correlation.
So when the default
mode network goes up,
the task positive
network goes down.
And so what we
wanted to identify
was whether or not
there is a similar kind
of anti-correlation in the
remitter and persistent group.
And what we found was this was
not observed in the remitters
or in the persistent group.
SUSAN WHITFIELD-GABRIELI:
In other words,
the persistent and remitted had
significantly less default mode
network anti-correlations
in regions
like the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex.
JOHN D.E. GABRIELI:
And that suggests
that the developmental
history of having ADHD
does leave an impact that
we can see in the brain.
And so it's a little of both.
It's both some remittance
clinically, but also
some continuation from
the childhood history.
First of all, it communicates
that some significant number
of individuals do improve,
in terms of clinical status.
The second thing is we
hope that the convergence
of different forms
of evidence will
help make people more
confident about the diagnosis
and treatment selection.
So this is a small
step forward, but we're
hoping that convergent,
objective scientific
information will start
to help make it easier
to see what the correct
useful pathway to help
a child or an adult.
[MUSIC PLAYING]